It's no secret that I love cats.
From having six fur babies of my own, to fostering a family of 7
to buying and reviewing every product imaginable – from the useless to the ridiculous, and volunteering at Sante D'or Foundation
or urging everyone that I know all the time to adopt, foster, and/or donate
I think it's safe to say: my love of cats is pure.
So when I found out that the world has lost over 96% of its wild tigers in the last century alone,
from a 100,000 to a little as 3,890, I felt devastated.
You know back when I was taking like two semesters of community college, I remember writing a paper
about how domesticated tigers in the United States were actually a huge problem
And I didn't realize that even that even more dire than that,
is the practice of illegal tiger trading.
Tigers are killed and sold for profit by international crime enterprises
who exploit ever single part of them
their skin, bones, whiskers and teeth
to make products like ornamental accessories and textiles.
So I am incredibly honored to be partnering with Tiger beer
to bolster the conservation effort of the WWF.
Tiger beer, who clearly loves cats as much as I do,
started a creative movement called #3890TIGERS
aimed at taking a stand against illegal tiger trading.
So #3890TIGERS is part of a six year global partnership between Tiger beer and the WWF
who are committed to doubling the world's wild tiger population to 6,000 by the year 2020.
And I know, being a part of a political cause these days can be confusing and hard and daunting.
I mean, how do you spread a message that you're passionate about
without coming across as preachy,
or how do you engage people in a simple but effective way?
I know that not everybody can physically volunteer
or has the financial ability to donate
But something that everyone can do is help spread awareness.
And Tiger beer has utilised the most powerful tool of spreading awareness in modern-day society
– the selfie.
Yeah dudes, the selfie!
These selfie art pledges powered by six global artists
raise awareness of the illegal tiger trading problem in visually powerful way.
You can visit 3890tigers.com to create your own and help me spread the word.
I'm Anna Akana,
don't let wild tigers disappear.